entre gilles verdez et vous citez pas là
ce n'est pas la folie mais j'ai
l'impression qu'il est très content de
voir yann mettrait parce que sans combat
est bon - honnêtement on a droit d'être
en désaccord sur plein de choses et de
temps en temps en accord ça oui oui très
rarement d'accord je trouve que le
chroniqueur que vous êtes n'est pas très
bon donc ça oui succès sur les i nouri
terre et ils vous très beau et vous
trouve mauvais aussi la raison non parce
que je joue moi je vous regarde pas donc
je veux pas vous trouver mauvais c'est à
dire je me trouve pas très bons non plus
d'accord non mais à chaque fois que je
fais les missions en sorte en juillet
malheureusement j'ai été moi j'ai la
caisse ou acheter parce que le problème
de cette émission c'est que vous ne
pouvez pas bien la faire c'est trop
compliqué vous ne pouvez pas être
content de vous après une émission comme
ça vous vous souvenez de tout ce que
vous avez raté
évidemment les répartit que vous avez
trois jours plus tard à zut ça y est je
l'avais moucher mais le moucher
quelqu'un dimanche quand l'émission
temps gelé jeudi ça sert pas à grand
chose et comme mon esprit de répartie et
se dilate de plus en plus avec la je
donnerai cours et vous avez préféré
travailler avec vanessa ou avec
christine angot je peux pas les comparer
ça n'a rien à voir c'est comme si vous
demandez tu préfères aussi l'hymne inuit
ce cop kevin blonde hitchcockienne la
guigne brunereau célinienne les deux me
vont